[Music]
you're listening to inside of you with
michael rosenbaum ryan you have a
mustache
i do
it's pretty intense it's pretty intense
i had to i was on a shoot that i had to
get my face trimmed very specifically so
i had like a sort of
uh like i don't know it was like there's
beard under my chin and like around it
was like a goat it was dr strange
you could really grow a mustache that's
a freaking mustache i am half mexican
how much you charge for the mustache
rocks boy
for you
free 25 cent 25 cents was that a thing
uh no i don't know
i had a shirt that once said that 25
cents for mustache rides
how'd that go over well in public i
don't know it was many years ago when
you couldn't get away with it oh sure it
was just a t-shirt i found some place
sure we're gonna do
uh
i hope you guys had a great week or
you're having a great week thank you for
allowing me to be a part of your week
and listening to us wherever you are
listen to your podcast i hope that if
you like today's podcast you'll you'll
listen to us you'll subscribe you'll
listen you'll give us a chance because
hopefully that's what you do there's a
lot of podcasts lots of choices and i
hope that you make us
your choice for a podcast so thank you
we've had some great guests i love all
the messages
i also want to give a shout to all my
patrons
you can support the podcast in many ways
but the most important way is patreon
p-a-t-r-e-o-n dot com slash inside of
you patreon.com inside of you join
patreon i'll send you a message become
one of my patrons
support the podcast uh ryan where can
the folks follow this podcast uh inside
if you pod on twitter inside to be
podcast on facebook and instagram that
is correct
um
also you can go to the inside of you
online store you can get some great
stuff mugs tumblers smallville merch
bunch of really cool like smallville
scripts
funko pops uh small of a lunchbox signed
by me and welling lots of cool stuff i'm
also on the cameo and uh
also go to sunspin.com if you want any
cool band merch and if you want to get a
zoom with me uh you could do that there
oh we had a great guest today
rahul kohli rahu koli rahul kohli i
think i said that right i love this guy
i love having him on uh he was in this
amazing show that mike flanagan directed
called midnight mass
he's constantly working
as he should
he was just so open and honest in this
interview and i think you guys are
really going to enjoy this one i
certainly hope so because i did rojo
thank you man thank you for uh
thank you for being open and cool i hope
we get to hang some time because i
really like this guy
um you got anything else up your sleeve
no just on my face just on your face man
you get that mustache
i woke up today and i chose joy that's
what happened he chose joy that's right
good for you that's right you deserve
joy in your life i am starting to agree
i don't think your girlfriend likes the
mustache that much does she she was uh
defense indifferent but i chose joy for
me good keep it keep it going be the new
ryan i think i will all right without
further ado let's get inside of rahul
kohli it's my point of view
you're listening to inside of you
with michael rosenbaum
[Music]
inside of you with michael rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience you're loving the collectibles
yeah now do you i i i saw something on
instagram we were looking okay and you
were painting these tiny figurines
what was it so are you a collector i i
mean i i kind of yeah like i
i definitely buy
[Music]
statues and these hot toy figures of
star wars and like legos so i'm i've
always been like that oh yeah but um and
sideshow i guess that's like a that's
from sideshow is it it looks familiar uh
raider's the lost ark
well as in
sideshow the ones who like who who sell
what
the
company
i was like sideshow what the [ __ ] is but
but um i
on top of that i
paint or make model kits or
i got into painting miniatures um
building
these things called gundams which are
like japanese mechs i i'm always
it basically it stemmed from
my own kind of cheap therapy
when i was struck really struggling as
an actor and
um
basically couldn't even get a line in in
in a soap opera uh it was mainly
commercials and background work how long
ago was that so
uh well going from the start when i left
drama school i did i went to amateur
drama school for a few years i got out
at like 20 and then i didn't buckeye
zombie which was my first role
for
what was that that had been i was 28 so
it's eight years wow yeah so in those in
that eight year period
um
i
the the thing is is
and
we're already deep diving political here
well you know i i would get seen for a
lot uh because it's a small pool the
diversity worked for me in that respect
and so
um
without very much experience or credit
or uh or coming from a reputable agency
i was still going up against riz ahmed
which made no sense but when you look at
the pool it does make sense because if
there's six of you you're still gonna
get seen right so i was super in the
running for things that i had no right
to book so i was constantly busy and
having to prep and getting these
monologues or getting to having to meet
with these directors
um and i flunked out of all of them and
then it would be riz or it'd be def
patel it'd be the the the guys that you
know would doing the thing and it's
pretty taxing on you yeah kind of i mean
it beats you down yeah um you're
defeatist the minute you walk through
the door you're kind of like
brizzy's gonna get this like
you always thought that you're like i'm
not going to get this i mean something
else is going to get there were times
where
the the problem with with that is like
especially in the early days i felt like
we were interchangeable so it didn't
matter what you represent like it's like
this for instance it's it's like um
harrison ford and mark hamill
are both
straight white actors
you wouldn't cast them in the same roles
because they bring a completely
different set of skills and charisma and
talent to their respective roles right
if you were south asian or you were from
a small diverse you know you were
representing a community um
it didn't matter what you brought you
were being seen for it so
because it was a you're interchangeable
does that make sense doesn't that make
sense
it's kind of [ __ ] right because the
main casting brief is brown
right so we're all in there whether
we're six foot four
five foot six
you know whether you're really funny or
you're really straight and dry so you're
doing everything and
is that a good thing i mean it
definitely sharpened my skills because
from week to week you know one second
i'm auditioning for a terrorist the next
i'm auditioning for the the kind of uh
gay best friend and then the next week
i'm auditioning for this i'm addicted
like and it it never had it never
settled so i i wasn't put the box i was
put in was brown
but i wasn't put in a characteristic box
right um
and
so so yeah like there were sometimes i'd
see something and i'd go oh
okay according if i ignore their ethnic
their ethnicity
this stuff i can do this is me this is
what i bring to something
i think
so there would be times where i'd feel
more confident going into that than i
would say i'd look at a rizz or i'd look
at dev and go oh i could do that
probably better off
out the gate than they could yeah
but it didn't matter
anyway did you feel like it was like
sometimes it's just a waste of your time
um yeah there was definitely a defeat
especially with the big stuff
the biggest what's the worst
in terms of how much time you spent on
an audition what's the longest you spent
working on an audition and didn't get
even considered
it happened recently
um i've deleted the tweet because i was
like am i allowed is this ndaid i
i auditioned for lord of the rings the
new amazon really yeah and i went i read
three or four times to no avail
um and how much material i mean it was a
monologue so it wasn't a huge amount but
it was
i remember
doing a tape in l.a doing another tape
flying into london to do it in person
but that was that was fine i mean it's a
big show and but but prior to that i
mean i had already done a zombie i
hadn't met mike yet we hadn't done blind
manor mike flanagan mike flanagan yeah
um
but uh
prior to that prior to i zombie the
worst audition i had led to me booking
my zombie
so
i had this it was a really weird day i i
got uh the night before you get the call
and that's also how you know you're
probably not gonna book it is when it's
a decent role and they call you the
night before you're like i wonder if
everyone else was called less than 12
hours prepared we need you they need you
tomorrow tomorrow they need this in this
is a big role you have an opportunity
like why are they rushing at the last
minute uh because uh they can't find the
right guy yeah yeah or so and so won't
do it yeah or that yeah or the guy that
they yeah the guy they want it's up in
arms right they're scheduling issues we
gotta you know maybe pad it out a little
bit i can't do that though i can't the
night before memorize a bunch of lines
and go in i need a couple of days sure a
couple days and what about you do you do
that
i'm good
you're good for the night i'm good i had
to be
i was out of like like i said it what
that period of time
um
and just before i move on to that actual
audition that's why i started doing
hobbies because
yeah i was super busy
super busy
couldn't really hold down a job because
it got to the point where i was asking
for so much time off and shift changes
when i was working in retail it became a
problem so i remember booking one
commercial that was like the first
decent amount of money i made it was
like 10 grand
and i was like i'm quitting like that's
it i've made my million so i quit my
full-time job i was sorry my retail job
to full-time audition what year was this
this would have been
2010 2011 so not that long ago no no not
that long ago i zombie happened 2014.
so i get the so that's how like
to stay creative to to i'm a bit of a
psychopath so like i needed something to
like
calm down and meditate and be okay with
just sitting at home sometimes on days
where you didn't have an audition or
whatever
and i got into model making i got into
just painting and airbrushing and i'd
get a little money from a commercial
background work i'd buy myself some
equipment to some tools and it was like
this will last me for the rest of the
month this is
it's it's an expensive hobby but
if you invest right
it can become quite cheap and it can
self-sustain and you just have your
paints and you can always just say well
that sounds yeah it sounds like you
might be saving a lot of money on
therapy right exactly and it does it
helps me to chill it just helps me to
like to sit down like the the old ways
of
i'm you know in english so
drinking and getting into fights and
pubs to let out whatever audition went
bad it's just not you know it's not
healthy so like yeah i went i found a
very kind of like
it didn't require anyone i could do it
any time of the day
i didn't need anything from anyone and i
was able to just think about stuff but
uh we have our night we we haven't done
a while but i have an art night at my
house because i'm terrible i hate i'm
not gonna criticize myself because it's
not something i want to excel in or
become it's not something i'm passionate
about or i want to make money off of or
it's like the be all end-all but it's
something that in therapy
that they recommended for me because i
was always afraid of it i'm you know
color blind and i'm color blind are you
yeah yeah i can't differentiate what we
got to talk about red brown green
uh blue green red green red green uh
blue i mean a lot of colors just blend
together i can't differentiate them yeah
that's crazy the art night um
sort of it's it's just it relaxes me
within like five or ten minutes
i'm just drawing i'm just doing the task
at hand i'm just focused on something
else other than myself other than all
these superficial things and so it did
help me along with therapy and other
things like that but that was your
therapy absolutely i mean like
if you
i'm emotional
and there's a lot going on all the time
and it's it's self it's self-inflicted
it's me and my brain and it's me
pushing things to a side and not dealing
with them immediately so they pile on
later and so there's a lot of noise
and then there's this moment when you
take all of your energy and mental power
like people have recommended meditating
and you just you sit down
and you zone out i can't do that the
brain goes even faster it's
it's worse
and it spirals and snowballs so
i found like with the miniatures which i
now bring to set so i bring them
whenever i travel because they're small
and i can take a travel just have them
in your trailer yeah or in my hotel
rooms in [ __ ] vancouver how long will
you spend it at any given time on them
it just depends like i could i can
focus on one
i don't know say i was doing a sword for
instance
and i was like i haven't painted it yet
it could take i could do it for an hour
and then jump in the shower and go to
dinner or i could decide today i'm gonna
do a lot more and get a lot more of it
done or
a few of them done so it's just it's
easy to pick up pause come back whatever
and then i find like
it it if i fall for it every time i sit
down i can be in any kind of pissed off
state or whatever or emotional
i start
you know you wet your brushes and you
start yeah i'm not in the mood i'm not
in the [ __ ] [ __ ] i don't want to do
it yeah and then before you know it you
haven't thought about anything
for the last 45 minutes except
what's in front of you and it's this big
and you're like
oh yeah here we go i haven't had a
cigarette i don't need food i haven't
had anything and i haven't thought about
whatever it is that was crushing on my
shoulders
so it's become my little escapism
wow yeah
so the audition
that came the night before was for 24
the london's edition like whenever he
was whenever jack bauer was in london
right
and
i got the call when it was like sites
would be provided to you
uh at the at the room in the room so so
they know you're gonna call reed yeah
yeah they knew there's something there's
something
there's a relief that you get if it's
like hey you're gonna read it when you
get there like everybody else you're not
you don't have to memorize this it can
be [ __ ] yeah
oh my god you already know there's a
safety net of shitness because they've
set up the turf so you're pretty much
reading it yeah you're reading the lines
and trying to look up here and there
yeah okay yeah um i get there and it's a
friday i remember this so [ __ ]
clearly it was really sunny in london
for february or whatever it was
and i get there and i
realized there's no sides and there was
a [ __ ] up
my team or the casting director didn't
send the sides to my team so my team
assumed that sides would be provided to
me so so the casting director was like
oh you weren't sent the materials
no okay took responsibility that there
was a [ __ ] up and then was like well let
me get them for you
we won't see you just now have a few
minutes to familiarize yourself with the
text
i still feel like okay this is special
treatment
she understands that we are we've had a
bit of an issue here or whatever
i get in the room and i start doing the
read and she doesn't like my read
and it kind of spirals into
a bad audition with someone's energy
being
impatient with me
and i wanted to be like yo like
step the [ __ ] off you know the
parameters you know what's happened why
am i being treated like this yeah
so
obviously the audition was a flop
i leave and that felt i was the worst i
felt because it was it was almost like
it was out of your control yeah it was
out my control but i still ate [ __ ]
and it was just this moment of then
getting another a 45-minute train back
home
on my you know i'm approaching my 30s
i've made no headway in this industry
and i feel [ __ ] i feel and i'm the butt
of the joke around the community and
friends and family and stuff you are or
you think you are i felt like i was with
certain people i definitely was and it
was like you know you're like you stay
it's like 37 year old still practices
with his band thinks he's going to make
it that's how it sort of felt at like 28
29 or 28.
i'm 49 and i have a band and i'm still
no you're gonna make it i probably no
but you know honestly i don't ever again
it's it's a passion for me i don't i
don't expect to be famous from it or
become rich from it i do it because i
really enjoy it that's what you got yeah
it's what i get out of it absolutely so
that's why yeah but continue that's it
everything like i've had worse auditions
but for some reason that day everything
it just hit me on this walk and i was
like i'm not doing this no more i can't
you're going to be done with acting i
was done
how old are you at this point 27 28 27
28 and that was the i was done
you're not you're not in the you're not
really in the room it's fake
it's like a ponzi sc it's something
something's fake's going on you're never
really reading and you're never really
in contention you can feel it
you have to like i don't know what home
run i'd have to hit in order to bump out
of this glass ceiling
but i'm i've i've wasted so much time
i need a new avenue and i so so
i rang my then uh agent
and was like i'm [ __ ] done
and i was pacing back and forth the
train station was like i'm done the way
i was just spoken to even though it
wasn't my fault
i can't keep taking this
like i i i'm done i'm done i'm done and
they that's brave even just say that
yeah to your agent who's like you know
you they want you to have confidence and
have passion for this i don't think they
cared
because they weren't like super high up
they were mainly commercial agent and
they
really booked a lot of at like
commercials
so it wasn't like i was with
united or someone who you know
they were kind of like oh all right like
it wasn't like a big deal having a
breakdown yeah exactly well and they
knew i'd come back or something i don't
know maybe we all do it
yeah yeah so
they were like well you know hold that
thought take the weekend i'm sorry that
you had a bad time in the meantime we
have just got an audition for you for a
pilot for rob thomas it's called izombie
and this happened at the same time at
the same train station acting yeah 100
and they said i zombie and i was like so
[ __ ]
it sounds like something terrible what
does it mean yeah it's a [ __ ] app
what is this like and and they were like
it's a comic book it's a pilot for the
cw
i was like okay cool whatever and they
sent the sides and i looked at it
and i attacked it in a way i wouldn't
have attacked it that weekend
i attacked it in a point to prove way
that i was
capable
that i had something to offer that i
that i could do this
dude i i like i'm not just filling in
the numbers what was it what did you do
i just i don't know i just studied in a
way i never studied before i drew i drew
lines
like when you know when you sketch out
an audition and the character
i feel like sometimes it's
sometimes it's in like light pencil if
that makes sense and other times you ink
it
yeah and you walk in and it's and
they're like whoa and it can work for
you or against you right but for some
reason it was it was inked it was
finished
this podcast is sponsored by better help
online therapy
everybody knows these guys
everybody loves them i love them ryan
that's great yeah yep it's helping you
getting a lot out of it amen look folks
relationships take work especially the
most important one you can have in your
life and that is your relationship with
yourself a lot of us will drop anything
to go help someone we care about we'll
go out of our way to treat other people
well but how often do we give ourselves
the same treatment
it's true we don't we're not good to
ourselves enough and you got to be good
to yourself and you'll learn how to be
good yourself but one of those things
you could do is join uh better help this
month better help online therapy wants
to remind you that you matter just as
much as everyone else does and therapy
is a great way to make sure you show up
for yourself ryan what would you say
better help is doing for you
uh it is helping me to uh
learn
about myself better uh how to treat
myself better uh
and just talking about things that are
bothering me however big or small yeah
because sometimes you think oh i have
friends to talk to you
no you can't be
absolutely open with your thoughts and
your demons and your thing just with
friends or you know people think they
take it it's so
easy you know like oh i don't need to
worry about that and it builds up and it
builds up and it festers and
we all implode at some point
so we got to take care of ourselves and
better help online therapy is there to
help us better help is online therapy
that offers video phone and even live
chat sessions with your therapist so you
don't have to see anyone on camera if
you don't want to it's much more
affordable than in-person therapy and
you can be matched with a therapist in
under 48 hours
give it a try and see why over 2 million
people have used better help online
therapy this podcast is sponsored by
betterhelp and inside of you listeners
get 10 off their first month at
betterhelp.com
inside that's b e t t e r h e l p dot
com slash
inside
thank you better help
couldn't do it without you you sort of
had
i've had this but it's it's a rare thing
when you just
you're sort of like [ __ ] it yeah rarely
do we ever say [ __ ] it we care too much
we need it we've got to escape
the stakes are high we need to make
money we need to impress people and
prove ourselves and
and you were at a position where you
were like
i'm gonna [ __ ] quit anyway and then i
got this and you know what [ __ ] it who
gives a [ __ ]
you had this for certain mentality or
your energy was just
what do i have to lose exactly there was
no stakes anymore
i didn't need to book this pilot it was
done like who rob thomas okay cool i've
met other showrunners or auditioned for
them who cares right i don't care all i
care about right now
is
going in and [ __ ] knocking an
audition out of the park because i feel
like it because i i need it for me i
need it for my confidence i don't need
the job right i just want to make some
noise
and i hit it that weekend in a way i
never hit it before
and this was a really i've said this
before in
in something but
it's a really good note for other actors
about their auditions if they're
watching
i couldn't wait to perform it and i
hadn't felt like that in a long time wow
like show and tell usually you're afraid
of it yeah and i was like i can't wait
to [ __ ] monday
what time two o'clock can't wait
because i knew it was good and i knew i
put work into it
and i get to the audition i remember the
character brief
it said highly caffeinated that was the
character brief this character is scotty
he's a highly caffeinated
uh medical examiner scotty scotty from
star trek ah he's that he's that kind of
like he's the brains and he's a little
bit bigger than life and all of this
stuff
so i get it i get it ready i get up on
its feet i remember like
showing it to my family and stuff like
that and they they liked it i've never
done that before but you showed them
your audition never done that before wow
yeah because it was this big monologue
it was the opening scene that the
it's one of the it's from the
it's the first time the character gives
basically exposition about who they are
where they're from what's going on and
they found out that the character is a
zombie or whatever so it's this big big
chunk of dialogue and um
on the train ride to like central london
i started to doubt myself and i was like
audition's too big
you're too big
you're too caffeinated
dial it back and by the time i've walked
to the front door of the audition uh the
carson director's place i've talked
myself out of doing what you wanted to
do yeah as big and fast as i could do it
so i started to dial it back and this is
the the best thing that's ever happened
to me my entire [ __ ] life where my
career is concerned
the room i sat in
i chose a seat randomly i sat here and
the casting director's assistant's
computer was there
okay and everyone was in the room and
we're all sitting there it was every
brown dude from england
we all look the same and we're all
sitting there and i could see on her
screen she was cutting together other
tapes and i could see multiple tapes
and they were playing people that she
liked
or she was just she was just
the auditions
and none of them even though i couldn't
hear audio none of them were moving
and i was like oh [ __ ] none of them are
highly caffeinated
no one's got any big energy everyone's
brought it down you could see
from their energy during their tape
they're like this
and they just and you're like
everybody's doing that everyone's doing
it
so i went [ __ ] that go back do do what
you could do do it fast it doesn't
matter if you trip up do it
so being able to see a computer i was
like all right i'm going to do what's
wait wait so this computer saved you
yeah like
this yeah because i wouldn't have done
it that way i would have i talked myself
out of it i was like it's too big
you're going too fast it's not it's not
right and i could see the screen and
then like i said i could see everyone
else's energy without even hearing the
dialogue was wrong i got in the room
name royal coley cool age did a slate
sit down
bang i hit it the minute it starts
and i and i didn't trip and i got
through the two pages of this this
[ __ ] dialogue i remember the cast
note to sat back and she went
have you auditioned for me before and i
was like i don't know maybe she's like
how long have you been doing this for
i was like eight years and she was like
where have you been
and i remember her saying that and then
i felt this like adrenaline rush and i
was like oh [ __ ] she likes me she likes
me because do you have a green card oh
like are you passport valid and
everything
so your heart starts pounding and i was
like uh
yeah i do she was like wow okay cool uh
well thank you so much speak to you
later a day later rob thomas had notes
come back in gives me a different scene
i do it now it's wednesday i do that
scene
friday i signed the contract i got the
one of the lead roles in my zombie
one week from the 24 audition seven days
and one week from the worst audition of
your life where you thought
i'm done
and a week later your life has changed
you have more money than i'd ever signed
for it wasn't great obviously it's
starting wage on it's better than retail
right absolutely
signed for a pilot never shot one before
i had more dialogue in scene one or by
zombie than i had in the previous eight
years and everything i'd done even in
student films were you nervous about
getting their all were you nervous about
being on film and actually doing this
and like this is your first job and you
look at all the work i have to do oh
yeah yeah i went hard i i that they
started the pilot i was one of the last
people cast because they had trouble
finding the character oh sorry the actor
so they had already had cast dinners so
i didn't even get the ease in yeah you
get to meet everybody and kind of have
they were like oh who's this guy let's
see what he can do yeah
and i
rob was so impressed with the tape
i
bypassed all network auditions screen
tests chemistry everything everything
else that all my other classmates who
were established went through i didn't
do any of them it was that tape
and then i found myself on a phone call
with rob
who just sort of spoke to me about the
character i went away for three weeks
studied like a madman
showed up on set and they had given me
12 pages
on my first day how long did you have to
learn them i had about three weeks i
knew i knew i knew that and they weren't
changing the lines weren't changing
rob locks them in they're very few
rewrites right um rob thomas is super
prepared like
so but like i said first scene of the
day even though we were shooting about
four or five in the morgue my first one
was more dialogue than i'd ever been
able to handle before
and then on for some reason on my f i
think it was a friday was my first day
in vancouver i'd never even left i
hadn't been on this side of the atlantic
so there's a lot of new things going on
through business class staying at the
sutton
i'm like what the [ __ ] good there's
headphones from the cw nice new
headphones with a with a card that says
welcome
i never got [ __ ] headphones you
didn't get headphones on their network
for [ __ ] i did so many shows for them
and i never got anything i mean i might
have got a jacket once i think that's
the only time i ever i it set the bar
and then everyone i've worked with like
netflix just gave me essential oils for
the house
well didn't you do well you also did uh
blind manor yeah for netflix yeah they
gave me what did they give us
i can't i know that usher was the
essential oils we got midnight my astro
netflix midnight mouse for netflix yeah
but the the headphones was the best
thing i ever got they were like high
quality earbuds better than i had
and it was a welcome card and it's never
been as good as that since but
my first day on a zombie
uh 12 pages 11 pages
for some dumb reason
dc comics were there
it was their day to visit the set and
it's your first day first day
uh chris robertson and his wife and
child the creator of the comic book was
also there with dc in video village rob
and all the producers and some cw
executives were all in on day one
i mean how do you [ __ ] do that i
would have a nervous wreck
you like
what did you do what did you kill it are
you doing your figurines
at that point i'm just sitting there
just rapidly painting to calm down what
you're doing
honestly when someone's that when you
when you're pushed into a corner like
that you know it's awesome you don't
push baby in the corner you fight back
you fight back yeah i hit it hard again
it was just like it was another one it
was it's the most strength
i've ever shown and
i haven't tapped into that since like
i'm back to being this coward lazy
bastard but like for some reason whoever
that guy was for a few weeks changed my
life
i'm still trying to find him again well
you can't be that lazy when you're
working with mike flanagan
you what i know from mike flanagan i've
talked to him i've talked to kate siegel
his wife who's been in everything
um
when you watch these shows you know that
you're going to get monologues and he's
not cutting away no it's on you
and
that is a lot of pressure for an actor
i've talked about this before yeah but
you it seems like you cannot be lazy you
have to do more work when you work for
mike flanagan than anybody else it seems
like
well
you do and then
he'll keep hiring you so you can be
like
like he like if he likes you right then
you get the call and he's like hey i
wrote this character for you i mean
there's nothing more awesome to like get
the call when you're like oh when are we
shooting and then the deal comes through
um but did you have any idea when you
got the set that you're like oh my god
he wants a warner
yeah
he would tell you
he does i mean he's
for sure
the actor's director yeah a hundred
percent and and he spoils you
and he's given me
i'm gonna blame him he's made me bad but
he badly behaved towards other i've
become impatient because i'm like why
aren't you giving me notes like mike
why are you not telling what's going on
and i've managed to put a lid on it but
it's definitely there because i've been
spoiled
with the last what is it about mike's
direction is he specific extremely
specific he's like a [ __ ] surgeon man
it's like
he knows he's a people person
and he's got wonderful social skills and
i think that's probably one of the most
important things for directors
communication right i think most of our
frustrations come from communication
and
mike what works for me won't work for
you won't work for them won't work for
that and mike knows exactly
what everyone likes he knows that this
person needs
a sit down
cuddling yeah
this person needs a jab in the room this
person used to be like [ __ ] off you got
it let's go yeah and he does that so
everyone gets this like different
version of mike
i i can get
over i don't know like i i don't like
overly long notes and like i'm not
i we haven't yet but even when we've had
character meetings because he likes to
meet with you and break down the
character before they usually derail
into like talking about star wars we
don't talk about the character we just
have fun
so he kind of already got the idea that
oh he doesn't he's not going to sit he's
just fun he wants to support you he
wants you to do great so just come and
do great yeah everybody's gonna have a
good time so his notes tend to be with
me bullet points
we'll do a scene
and then mike will come over and it'll
take me aside and he's like
and it's as concise as it can be it's
almost like what if it wasn't
and you go oh
and it just it's the like it's the
opposite of the thing you were thinking
about yeah and it changes the day and
you know and then he disappears like a
[ __ ] magician and you're like
what if it wasn't i hadn't considered it
if it being the other way and then you
do it
and then it's and and i love that i love
that he doesn't
he doesn't crowd me he doesn't he
doesn't try to score me he
he's so encouraging and
um but we we started with blind manor
which was
i didn't know
i i i knew mike's well i'm not a horror
fan
i'm a die-hard heart look around you
evil dead post yeah thing aliens friday
the 13th yeah that's a huge horror fan
yeah i hadn't watched anything i hadn't
watched the shining oh my god have you
seen it now yeah because we he did a
screen in the dock to sleep yeah so i
was like oh i should watch the first did
you like the shining
yeah
you didn't love it
i had issues would you have issues let
me guess the issue is
jack became too evil too fast he was he
was a psycho in the me interview
oh he was kind of like yeah i was like
it starts with him and he's like he's
going to kill his fam like in the in
well the guy does look at him go well mr
torrence there is one more thing um
there was a man he came up here with his
family um
he was the caretaker he was a good man
no one ever had a problem with him but
somewhere along the line he had what
some people get
it's called cabin fever and he uh
he chopped his daughters up with an axe
and blew his brains out with a shotgun
well that's terrible
yeah but yes he got he gets he's there
already he's got those eyes and he's
like but there's a girl also a great
line
we're uh i i'm just a nerd but what's
her name shelley de long comes in the
room and she says jack jack
someone's here at the hotel they hurt
danny and he just looks and goes
you out of your [ __ ] mind
it just always killed me yeah i thought
it was brilliant
it's brilliant who am i to sit here and
and slag off kubrick
but
i i got to watch it like i said i mean i
watched it and i i had some issues with
it um
i did feel like i mean no one's ever
gonna trust me we're talking about
mike's works concerned
but it felt like
dr sleep was a really cool firmware
update
that kind of like patched some of the
things i had issues with when i said wow
it like
i i mean i'm i i think i have an
understanding that king really liked dr
sleep too because he felt like it
patched something right right because he
had major problems with the shining yeah
major problems in kubrick so
um but but i had to do like uh
i don't know a whole lifetime's worth of
like getting used to horror so the first
thing so i booked blimey mano and i
wasn't like offered it or anything i
just finished a zombie and i was scared
you probably watched haunting of hill
house that
research as a researcher right i booked
it first so i i knew of the hill house
because of that wanna
that episode like i remember it being
like going viral on twitter and
did you know that this is five
scenes stitched together and that's the
whole episode so i knew it from a from a
filmmaking point of view but i didn't i
never watched it was that the one in the
funeral home yeah oh yeah unbelievable
yeah because that episode became
like well known just like i remember the
making off was posted on on twitter so
that's how i was aware of it um
but i i zombie finished and then it's
the you know
can you make magic happen again and book
another role can you book roll number
two because that lasted for five years
right um and i was terrified uh you're
terrified of what
not having a show of what's next what's
next where do i go you saved your money
and you know you
you didn't
i thought i i i went mental are you a
partier i was you were a partier when
you say party drugs alcohol
not drugs i was never really uh on the
drug scene i
i'd never lived away from home and i'd
never really had disposable income and a
zombie
shot in vancouver
by the way a lot of our crew were uh ex
smallville oh man scott graham was
already producing love scott he still
loves money
he does he owes me money on a hockey
game we said that you know the rangers
had a better record at the end of the
season than the mate believes
thousand dollars he owes me a thousand
scott gray he never paid me back that's
[ __ ] up it's [ __ ] up it is and it
wasn't like the guy was poor
he's he's on riverdale now is he yeah so
i'll find him yeah i'll find him i know
it is i don't know
i know but go ahead about to do so about
being in vancouver yeah and so yeah so
like just so you know whenever we were
doing a zombie
the truck had the s logo because it was
smart
so it was all x moorville because it's
it's got right so i always felt this
closeness to you guys because
you were the benchmark because everyone
spoke so highly of of smallville while
we were shooting oh man we had a good
time it was it was it could be intense
sure it could be very intense doing 22
episodes a year [ __ ] up in vancouver
and it's raining all the time and it's
grace guys as you know which probably
prompted you to drink
it did
it did it did it does and it's it's yeah
it's super privileged problems i get it
but you know
it what turned into like uh blow off
steam friday turns into a
tuesday wednesday thursday friday
saturday so you could you drink a lot
heavily heavily every day yeah like how
what's heavily like what's one day of
drinking i mean it wasn't like
eight beers oh no it would have been
like
uh
i i would do half a bottle of
jameson
half a bottle and james and then like
vodka sodas
you can drink that much i was at that
time i'm a lightweight now and you're
like 32 at this point yeah i was between
28 and yeah 28 and 33 was dude and you
could still learn all your lines do all
your [ __ ] come prepared be a pro i
couldn't keep the weight off though
inside of you is brought to you by
patreon patreon that's
that's my podcast my podcast you can
support the podcast by going to patreon
p-a-t-r-e-o-n dot com inside of you i
will leave you a message afterwards
patreon is an awesome place to meet
people a lot of people become friends on
there it's a platform to talk about
podcasts my podcasts
i hope
there's different tiers some people i
give boxes of merch and i write a little
letter at the end of every couple months
to them uh there's different things for
different people but overall i love the
support
that my fellow patrons give me
if you want to get early access to
episode content
check out the patreon
if you want to interact with other fans
on the show check out the patreon if you
want to get exclusive access to have
your questions ask during the show
check out the patreon i mean if you just
love what we do and you want to keep
this train rolling just check out the
patreon check out the patreon william
for the love of god i i literally i
wouldn't be here without you folks and
that's all i'm going to say join patreon
thank you patreon.com inside of you
support the podcast i'll write you a
message right after
yeah i saw on twitter you were very
brave you put a before and after picture
of like him ripped up and and before you
were a little you know you're a little
pudgy you weren't lying
i don't think you're a big boy you were
just a little overweight yeah a little a
little sloppier yeah and then you were
like in shape yeah but to show that it's
kind of like i have times where i'm like
i hope nobody sees me
but you should like put it out there
that's nice it's i i
yeah i mean like
i guess it's but some people can still
misinterpret that because they're like
well
you know they everyone thinks that they
have such a misconception of what we do
how much money we make and how much
studio help you have
so i think public perception is as well
of course if you're on a marvel show or
you're this they have the the farm
and everything's taken care of i could
get into shape and it's like no i was
just fat i needed to be in shape for
mike's thing so he asked her to be in
shape for it no
it was just a choice
i thought it was unprofessional of me to
show up on set in that shape for that
character it wasn't a character it
wasn't that the character was written
for the sheriff or blind manor for asha
oh
this is new yeah the fall of the house
of usher yeah yeah i just wasn't in
actor shape i think there's a level of
like
shape we
i'm 36 years old
i shouldn't be showing up to set like
that yet
i'm sure there'll be one one day where
i'll happily just be they'll be like
[ __ ] hell yeah that's what we need
and they're not gonna say anything but
that's not it's not the world that i'm
in right now and it's not what
i i
mike's relationship with myself he's
definitely
taken me under it feels like he's taking
me under his wings slightly well kate
says the kids call you rubble rubble
yeah i mean they love you
right they've got the they're living in
a pixel movie their kids are straight
out of a pixel movie they break like as
soon as you see them and talk to them
you feel like she was like he loves kids
he loves the kids love him yeah do you
want to have kids absolutely you do yeah
absolutely i i feel like the job
right now any type of responsibility is
tough because
i'm approaching i just got i was about
to say bad news i'm gonna get trash for
this
um a show that i
auditioned for there was a a i did a
pilot recently and um
it's not mike it was like my team were
like hey you should maybe think about
also collaborating with other people and
i'm like no
um but then they had this they had this
pilot and it was it was great um and
here's the selling point uh decent money
shoots in la
when do you ever [ __ ] hear that no
and i was like i'm gonna shoot in los
angeles at this point i did five years
in vancouver
then i did blind manor and a couple of
others midnight mass usher
yeah so i'm approaching nine years this
is my sound like me yeah we could have
made supernatural or small together i
did seven years of smallville i did two
years of impaster i did a movie there
so i'm about nine nine years in the nine
years yeah
yeah and
i kicked myself because like i've never
known
that i was gonna be there that long like
maybe on smallville you guys knew you
you were coming back right
well you know
they always said well i don't know we
don't know but yeah they never gave us
like a like awesome supernatural picked
up for two more seasons already and this
is picked up for another right they
never did that with us oh so you're the
same yeah we're the same we were the
bubble we found out the night before the
up front every year that's so
disrespectful
just [ __ ] come on like you know
you've moved now you've packed yeah
you've left you've come back to your
place
they want to put you in your place they
want you to know that you know they're
powerful and you're not and they'll give
you i'll tell you when you're working
and you know don't ask for more money
you're lucky to be that we're getting
picked up and i don't know i i i feel
like that sometimes
it probably is it
you look back at it and people go to you
oh man you should have bought a property
when you're out there why why would i
bought a [ __ ] property on a show
called i zombie that had a 0.2 in the
nielsen ratings
and was a bubble show that had one
billboard
in five years on sunset and that's the
that was the marketing budget
why would i have ever considered this
has got legs this is gonna [ __ ] go
i'm gonna buy a property yeah of course
i pissed it away and i didn't care and i
was like
living to
every year was a goodbye every year we
said goodbye to the crew we said goodbye
to each other and then may
the upfronts
you would hear apparently
they gave rob a call and said we might
be coming back and then it so you're
always rebooking that show and then
moving back out so it's a [ __ ]
upheaval you i've lived in you live in a
different apartment every time yeah
with the same [ __ ] leasing agents
trying to get a furnished plate we're
all just interchanging yeah one's over
there in yale town and then the other
one's over he's just doing the same [ __ ]
mix it up yeah just mix it up and then
when i auditioned i got out of that when
i auditioned for bly manor it was uh
england i believe was the audition and i
was like okay i'm i'll work at home i'll
go back and work and i book it and
uh from a tape that i just did and and
um i got the part of blind mana and then
my agent called me and she was giggling
you're going back again back to
vancouver and i was [ __ ] done by the
end of my zombie which was february
and this was
august i want to say i got the call
and
i
i was like okay it's fine it's a good
job it's mike flynn again it's netflix
i'll be fine and
i went up there and then on my first day
mike kind of did this size up thing and
said something
that made me feel like oh i'm being
sized up for something else
and then he did it again
and then he asked me something another
time he's like how old do you reckon you
could play like how was that what's the
little max you reckon you could you
could legitimately play and i was like
late 30s early 40s and he's like okay
and at some point i reached out to mike
and i was like what's going on
and he was like let's have a meeting and
i flew back to la and sat down with him
and he pitched me midnight mass
in november so i'd only and i'd only
worked on him he only directed the pilot
of bligh so he only saw you for the
pilot
and then offered you the part for
midnight
yeah and he was like can you do an
american accent i was like nope but that
didn't matter you did not i've never
done that you learned one kinda it was
perfect thanks man yeah i know i didn't
know you were english no i never never
done one and like
oh we lost that we didn't have a dialect
coach because it covered because we were
the first show back so you learned on
your own yeah well i had one on zoom but
i didn't have one on set mike was mike
would come back and go
it's car and i'd go [ __ ]
because he was helping me because you
said car i got a car yeah car the
sheriff there's one scene where the
sheriff does just speak english and goes
sturge all right yeah what we've had a
brown out every time i watch that scene
i'm like why didn't i even [ __ ]
attempt but um
but yeah he he he offered me that and i
knew it was vancouver
and i was like okay
i mean the show is [ __ ] phenomenal
the pitch was amazing i wanted so badly
to play this sheriff and
we were gonna he was like you're gonna
have three weeks you're gonna rap bly
you're gonna have three weeks prep
so he tells me this in november he's
like yeah you're gonna have three weeks
prep we go straight into midnight mass
so i was talking to my team and i was
like well
i
i'll be done by june
and
like it's basically like almost one show
i went from a blind manner to midnight
mass without a break i can keep the same
apartment it's kind of like you know
it's it's easy
i'm staying
um so and the only thing mike told me in
november was was
uh
put on weight because i was too slim and
i was slimming blind man and we wanted
to look a bit bigger in age and bit
daddy
so bit weathered he's been there yeah
he's been like he's dealing with his
son's [ __ ] yeah yeah and like we
figured i figured like uh you know
hey you know weight makes you look older
and and
there's no gym on the island maybe
you're a doughy sheriff now that used to
be a you know fit nypd cop so basically
it was fat jason mamoa i remember the
first conversation we had was like long
hair i had the scar
beard we were going for an earthy look
so from you do look older in it yeah i
mean a lot older it's crazy yeah cause
you have some grays yeah they put them
in some grass
but what happened was
i put on 30 pounds for
for mass or fat wow so literally
midnight mass midnight mass oh yeah and
i did it the bad way because again this
isn't marvel i like i was eating
mcflurries
i was eating doughnuts i'm not healthy
no so i i got really bad health issues
so what happened was i get fat in blind
manner you can half see it if you start
watching the back end i'm like the
apron's like
it's [ __ ] tight
and i'm doing what i'm doing so i've got
three weeks man
three weeks to get this this guy up on
its feet and we we get it up on its feet
i'm now 30 pounds heavier
and then we have a table read of all
[ __ ] seven episodes
of midnight all seven yeah in one day
never done that that's exhausting yeah
oh my god that's like that's like seven
hours check the date march 11th
2020.
so we hear rumors about this covert
thing's [ __ ]
weird isn't it it's it's a bit more
serious than we thought
we've all flown in from different places
we're sitting in this tiny room in an
office 17 of us or whatever just like
all right are we doing the next scene
and like that's the room and we're like
this is [ __ ] weird uh
and on the
the day after i got a call from trevor
masou's uh our producer and he was like
go home we're taking a two-week break
because of this covered lockdown
we're all on flights within an hour or
two back to la and then we didn't shoot
mass until august july
and in that time so what turned into two
weeks turned into like five months but
now you have to keep on that way
that's exactly what happened and i was
waking up in the middle of night
vomiting stomach acid
swear to god it was like reflux or
whatever yeah i'd like because i was
still trying to keep it on and i
couldn't it wasn't my frame i remember
i'd go to sleep and just be like
and it would be like down me it'd be in
the bed and like
i spoke to mike and i was like i can't
do this
and i remember had a conversation with
kate and and also my best friend who was
a consultant on midnight master who's
our islamic consultant
and
being brown and like she's like you're
kate was kate's been amazing for me but
she she was like you're a leading man
why are you making it hard for them to
see that she was like be the best
version of yourself on camera
make the sheriff hot lose the weight get
do whatever
and i was like they're right and even my
my best friend who i said was the
consultant he was like
man i want to see
the hot muslim [ __ ] why can't we have a
like why can't you be the guy
be the guy don't be fat jason momoa be
the guy so i sent mike a picture of joel
from the last of us the video game and i
was like what do you think of this
instead
this was around june-ish a couple months
before we started filming and he was
like i love it do that so i had to lose
it all for no reason so i lost it all
got and your health got what got better
yeah i still get acid reflux even now
really yeah that's never gone so even
now i'm like i get it when i have like
cheeseburgers before i go to bed yeah
it's gonna it can't be late
nowadays yeah that's the thing
hours earlier stop it yeah you never had
a basement
really you don't want that
i now get nervous if it's a late night
snack i'm like
i don't want to have this at night i
don't want to almost die yeah
how how did you quit the drinking or or
how did you slow down how did you stop
doing five days a week i zombie stopped
i zombie you stopped it for the work
as soon as the show was over it stopped
i've never drank like that since what so
what do you what was the meaning behind
drinking being alone being in vancouver
being alone being in vancouver being on
that show
dealing with work politics
uh you were depressed yeah you were
depressed and the alcohol was
blowing off steam partying just partying
and i wasn't like i didn't feel like i
was an alcoholic i didn't have a problem
but then i don't know you look back at
it and you're like [ __ ] now we used
to polish off a lot of drinks yeah you
know and then you know this and i
started hearing back the stories about
things i did or places i went and i'm
like
bad parts of town you didn't go to
hastings did you i went to hastings yeah
that's a rough area oh yeah it's a super
rough area you gotta be careful
yeah but yeah it just it went with the
job early on you said you're an
emotional person
what does that mean what kind of
emotions are are you someone that cries
a lot yeah you do cry a lot everything
really every emotion so you can you get
angry often yep in the same day as
crying so you could lose your [ __ ] one
day and cry yeah and be happy
really and have the best day do you do
you like that about yourself or is it
something that you're working on so you
can control that
i i don't like it you're like i don't
know cause like does it does it work for
you is it
i i haven't
figured it out yet because my mum will
tell you
that i've always been like that as a kid
just extremities of emotion
and then i i did need therapy after i
zombie and i tried therapy for the first
time and it felt cliched
really oh yeah well it felt cliche to do
it because i was like of course of
course you now live in la
and you're a little london boy and
you're sitting there going i think my
grandad was this and like so if it took
a while for me to feel
and i felt like i was
i was doing some really weird [ __ ] in
therapy
i was so self-aware
i felt like i was bullshitting
i felt like i was on in an interview
you're making them like you yeah i was i
haven't done that where you're just like
yeah you know i don't have a problem
with that no yeah you know it's like so
what are you up to this weekend what'd
you do this isn't this is about you
this is about making you better this is
about getting all your demons out yeah
and once you can sort of relax into it
and stop that [ __ ] and the truth
starts to come out that's when it's
therapeutic yeah i never got to that
part you never got to that part no i was
still in the performing get trying to
get validation waiting for the therapist
to be like well i've seen your work and
you're a fantastic actor
you're very handsome
and i felt like i was
just trying to manipulate therapy and
but what came from it
was
a mild form of a diagnosis of bipolar
wow
uh called psycho cyclothermia or
something and it was like high highs low
lows in between
massive spending mass power oh so she
asked your question she or he she yeah
she she asked you all these questions
and then said based on your answers
i'm pretty certain you have bipolar or a
form of bipolar and i'd like to medicate
you did it freak you out yeah
so what'd you say i had a mistrust
especially from american medicine right
we don't we don't shove pills down in
britain we just go to bars and fight and
yeah we get out we go to the football
game and you get into a shower liverpool
all right the beatles are from here
right
[Laughter]
you nailed it that's yeah that was
that was the uh yeah so it was it was
like
she wanted and then the the [ __ ]
stupid actors man
you hear that and you're like
but what if that's my juice
right what if that's what i'm makes you
you makes me me and i go on set and i
can hit a 10 like no one else can hit a
10.
in a motion what if that's if it's my
disease like as long i think the key is
as long as your lows aren't so low where
it becomes dangerous for you right and
that's why you have to have sort of a
mid-level some kind of a homeostasis for
sure yeah yeah yeah otherwise you know
it's like because the highs can be
wonderful right
and the lows can just be like dismal
you're like i don't want to be here
absolutely so what do you do
i
don't feel like the lows ever got there
to a certain degree it's it's
i'll have bad days
i want to quit
i don't want to leave the house i won't
shower for three full day like that can
happen yeah but it's controlled i'm all
right i don't feel like i'm in danger to
myself i don't get abusive with my loved
ones or anything like that are you
somehow like aware of it like you're
you're going through it i feel like [ __ ]
i feel like [ __ ] you're like but i have
bipolar so just be aware of it i am now
you are now so that was beneficial
before it was just part of the charm
right before it's just i am what i am i
just killed midnight
but it was like you would just it would
be it would be
kind of like
kind of just put down to something
whimsical like he didn't eat
i mean he's a scorpio or he's you know
whatever he's being sassy because
someone said something to him on twitter
but then when i got that kind of like
early diagnos like that diagnosis
it does now
i'm more open about it with people so
i'll be like
i'm i'm i'm i'm i'm having a downward
one i'm cool
and it's worked so so i'm in control i
never took medicine or anything so
really yeah so i feel fine
um will you work out a lot i
yeah it depends for the role
yeah but don't you think that like does
it help you because i've talked about
this with other people but working out
helps the mind it helps the body helps
all that so you're less depressed or
with someone with bipolar doesn't really
affect that i don't feel like it
i i that would be a question for other
people i think
i think i've been in a better place
since i've been training i'm definitely
worse i don't know if it's a cure
but there's worse in working out like
yeah yeah like you don't i think there's
a mood change and a bit more pep yeah
and less bad days with the gym but it's
not like night and day it's not like
i'll have a bad day and i go you know
what i need i need to do some flies
right and then i'll be great it doesn't
it doesn't work like that
but consistent training and looking
after your health of course i feel
a better version of myself and a better
worker but
um
yeah the news i got was that show
which so after midnight mass and then
usher
vancouver by the way what's the fall of
usher about
it's a edgar allen
poe yeah yeah it's mike's mike is i
don't remember what it was about though
it's i think it was the fall of an uh
sure
it was about a guy who visits and usher
and usher is
got a sister
i look really bad i'm in the midst of
filming him
it doesn't matter as long as you know
your part who cares yeah exactly
seriously uh
but yeah i mean
it's it's
mike's done it with shirley jackson with
the hill house and he did it with um
uh henry james with turn of the screw
he's he's doing his
adaptation of edgar allan poe in the
fall of the house of usher um wow and um
it's it's great i mean we knew he does
this thing
where just as you're getting
ready to do one job mike tells you about
the one that's around the corner that
he's thinking of you like fall really
yeah so i remember midnight mass
once we were kind of up and filming he
was like there's this role yeah and fall
of house of usher and he drops that seed
in your do you love when he does that
it's like a little gift doesn't it
absolutely what a gift he did it on the
meeting for russia he dropped another
one and i was like
really and then there's another one
after this maybe yeah and that's why you
can't tell what that is sure but yeah he
always i feel like he's done that
consistently with me which is like
you know hey welcome so you know
how you feeling how you feeling about
the character cool by the way
here is this other thing for you to
think about and you're like what's uh so
he but um but yeah so usher's up in
vancouver so i flew in but uh as i got
to the airport
uh lax on thursday they the they rang to
say congrats show's been picked up
this pilot the uh only difference is
uh it's not shooting in la anymore we're
moving production to vancouver
and i spiraled
i think you should talk to your
therapist and get on meds for the bible
do you reckon no
i don't know what i'm not a doctor that
was a joke because you know you're going
back to vancouver absolutely no yeah i
feel like vancouver
yeah i i need to i need to address
whatever it is about vancouver it's
it's look we love canada i do i love it
i love vancouver it's great to visit
and i would say maybe to live
but like it's so gray all the time and
rains
it's one of the most beautiful cities in
the world in the world you have to go to
vancouver yeah
for a month
yeah but if you want to move there
right here's the key
know that you want to move there know
that this is what you can expect this is
what you're expecting i've i've somehow
moved there
for a decade against my will
that's the issue and i think it could
have been any city it could have been it
could have been atlanta it could have
been anywhere in the world but it's just
the fact that it it's it's like a
running gag now and it's like you know
yeah it's vancouver so i'm i i rap usher
i'll leave and pack
come home
stay in la for a month or two and then
i'm back up
for their autumn winter
yeah
hollywood problems great you know what
you're getting roles that every actor
would want it's it's true like if i was
going up there to shoot some shitty
series i'd be [ __ ] miserable yeah
that's just me yeah i don't care people
say well you're you're working i don't
care if it's not good i don't want to do
it you want to do work that's not good i
don't that's just me it doesn't mean
everybody some people like to work on
shitty shows
all for it i'd rather not do that same
thing making a point right okay
okay
one but is it is it any worse than
england though
it's the same identical on the weather
app
day by day they just vary a degree or
two and it's both it's the same so
that's where you're from that's where
i'm from which makes me more angry
because l.a
at least the weather is always nice oh
god it is beautiful and i don't want to
be that person but like you can't help
when you get out of lax and it's behind
you and there's a [ __ ] show's done and
you finally you know your cab or
whatever pulls up outside and you step
out and you hit palm trees yeah
blue sky yes and smog
and smog even the smoke and you're just
like you're just like i'll take it
yeah the air quality is 20 percent today
i'm like give a [ __ ] sun's out yeah and
it does it changes my attitude and um
there's when we did the pilot
i
i remember freaking out
and saying things that
again
very privileged problems but like little
things that other people probably don't
consider and i was like
i woke up in my own bed
got changed out of my wardrobe
made a coffee on my coffee machine got
into my car and drove the set
do you know how [ __ ] precious that is
like
all i did was wake up in my own space
that was it means a lot it means a super
it's crazy it's a big deal yeah as
opposed to what i'm doing on usher right
now which is waking up in the sutton
that's depressing
you should have you should have rented
somewhere yeah i should have that's the
one year i didn't but i'm okay with it
but because it's it's not as a it's not
as long a commitment but like
being in a hotel room and and
face time you know what i mean you're
just you're never comfortable in your
own skin you know you're living out of
the science constantly ordering food
room services
yeah same [ __ ] the chicken noodle soup
and the grilled cheese sandwich they
still do the chicken noodles they still
do that oh yeah i mean i like them they
were always very kind it's funny because
uh there's a kid that picked on me back
in school so that was my um
my name what's it called my alias name
that i used was chicken noodle soup no
not chicken no
no i wasn't chicken but it was called my
name was whatever and let's let's say
for all shits and giggles it was it was
uh toggles
my name was toggles my you know the guy
that picked me was toggles
or toddly toddly john toddley was his
name i'm getting a point
and my brother was with me at the hotel
and as i walked in the hotel the guy the
uh
the manager looked at me goes
good morning mr togley
and he started laughing because he knew
it was the name of the guy the kid from
school in school so he loved that so
good morning mr toddler and i forgot i
told him that and it was just like but
it was a funny moment all right
it's by the way i'm saying you're right
it's rahul coley coley yeah it's not
rahul yeah well you say it fast i do
yeah
this is called [ __ ] talking with rahul
coley
yeah this is my these are my patrons
this is the thing called patreon and my
patrons give back to the podcast yeah
and they really support it and they're
awesome and some of them get to ask
questions
go to patreon.com inside of you
right that's what it is all right here
we go rapid fire oh wow okay yeah
leanne asks what is your all-time
favorite horror movie well the thing
that he doesn't watch horror movies but
you gotta have one 28 days later does
that count sure
yeah i like that one yeah it was
fantastic 28 days later and then there
was 28 weeks later
did you like that one it was all right
it was all right yeah
lisa h my question is what does he
really think about the ending of i
zombie i thought it seemed rushed and
could have been done differently
thoughts yeah i thought it sucked did
you yeah i did yeah i was super
disappointed i didn't like that we
jumped 10 years into a
uh i will you know we just did a wrap-up
exposition scene in a vr room it made no
[ __ ] sense uh where people just
pissed i don't know i never i never
really cared enough to look how other
people felt i know that we were sitting
there like is this how it ends is this
what we're doing
you know you still do your job do your
job
michelle k how do you decide which
projects to go after what attracts you
to certain ones character character
character character not even story
character by the way how important was
it the 911 monologue you had in midnight
mass how important was that it's a real
it was a real uh
mike wrote it from an article from a
real person yeah there's someone else's
story there was a police officer spoke
about working for the nypd uh post 911
uh so one of the first things that mike
had sent to me along with the scripts
was read this article um and it was
these are real things that happened and
the suspicion and
um
oh [ __ ] maybe they their plan was to
infiltrate us
and then they flipped and like
yeah it was it was a super important
jumping off point was it hard to do that
monologue
yeah it was that was one of the toughest
days i've ever worked in my entire life
was that a couple pages of my life it
was originally five
five or six pages it was american accent
again never done one before didn't have
a dialect coach on set
um it was the day blind mana launched
um and it was i was told uh
one slow pushing
so i knew we weren't going to break it
up and cut into it
so i knew that if i [ __ ] up
pronunciations of one word it's staying
because we're doing it and mike has a
zero adr rule on set
how many takes
three i think how many pages
five originally i think it was it was
longer i think it got cut down a bit
there's a good there's a good chunk
missing but did they give you apple time
when it's cut down
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah so you had a
couple weeks to look oh i mean i i had
that i had that all the scripts from
mike are done and given to you months
before you start production leah s loved
you in blind manner in midnight mass any
stories you could tell us about working
with mark hamill in fall of the house of
us
it just happened i know you can't do it
can you yeah it was a is i mean i became
an actor because of star wars
you became an actor because of star wars
did you tell him that yeah what do you
say
he said i've heard that before he said
that i'm glad i haven't shared this with
anyone this um
we had our first my first day was with
mark
um and when we got into like you know
between takes and stuff you talking i i
told him and he sat back and he was like
really and i was like yeah 11 years old
got the box set and made a decision i
wanted to be a part of this world so i
learned the tools
to get into this world
and he said well i'm glad we made
something that uh
made you become an actor because i think
you're brilliant and i got very
emotional and i was like oh
that yeah how'd you get emotional yeah
yeah that's good uh 11 like i could tell
you're a little bit almost emotional now
remembering it it's um
you did it you did the thing so there's
something validating about setting a
goal
and i didn't do the thing because i
haven't done star wars
i got something a little bit better than
that because who's to say you'd ever
even get to work with luke skywalker
right and then you're talking to the
you're talking to the guy and the guy
says hey i like you you're great and i'm
glad that we
set you on a journey
it's better than uh a rolling book of
boba fett
is it though i i may have promised i'd
never talk [ __ ] about a star wars
project live i won't i won't talk [ __ ]
but i will say mandalorians a lot better
lauren's fantastic it's just you know
what it is it's character the character
you care about more i just really cared
about the mandalorian i care about
little yoda yeah i care about like the
characters um
but booker boba fett has some great
moments but it's just it's it's
not character driven i feel like the
boba fett we wanted to see a show off is
called the mandalorian yeah that yeah
that's it
wait a minute boba fett amanda lauren's
kind of like boba fett let's just keep
that yeah with that yeah yeah um all
right raj
was your family supportive of your
choice to pursue an acting career anyone
try to discourage you along the way
yes i was very fortunate i think
my mum was probably the most
apprehensive
because
she knew i was a bit of a fuck-up
and like i don't know if he's got the
discipline or the smarts to to do this
so she was nervous for me but it was
from a place of love not right not like
embarrassing she's just worried worried
i think mum does the worrying dad was
like
you just dropped out of school to what
you want to be an actor have you thought
this through do you know what you're
doing no and then the next day he came
up with a brochure for an acting school
and said well if you're going to do it
do it [ __ ] properly learn the tools
you trade
so that was dad yeah that must have felt
good yeah and it it was like i don't
care what you do just do it properly
uh and do it right and the the matriarch
of our family was my grandmother
who you know
old indian lady been through
crazy stuff and and and i was she always
had certain affection for me in
particular of all her grandkids from
jump she was like
i got you i support you
so i i was very fortunate i didn't i
know a lot of people within the
community particularly like south asian
communities you go into very specific
job sets and the arts isn't one of them
um
so i was definitely
[Music]
kind of seen as a bit of an idiot
by the kind of more extended family
community i think everyone in my family
thought i was an idiot for doing it
still no still just in general
still think it's that way i
uh
it's i'm still dealing with the fact
that because now i've done it and i i
did what i said i do i find it very
difficult to be fake around the people i
know didn't
believe in me and i'm like oh that you'd
like what someone at your workplace
likes my show and you want to sign
something shove it up your [ __ ] ass
do you say that yeah
yeah i'm a [ __ ] i don't care i'm not
who who can you cry this is my question
who do you cry in front of the most
who can you cry in front of the most
i'll card find anyone anyone you'd cry
in front of me yeah you don't care if
you were emotional done something you
cry i cried in front of mike uh over
pizza i don't care
oh it's there it's it's real i've never
been discouraged from it uh
my parents i've never been discouraged
from showing emotion and even ugly cries
i'm sorry
oh yeah yeah even ugly cries i don't
care good for you man that's probably
why you're such a good actor you don't
give a [ __ ] i can't do it on cue though
so it's useless with the glycerin that's
true yeah the little one in your eyes
yeah but it's uh
i it doesn't really help with work
it's just i don't i don't care uh last
thing is more of a statement omar says
your performance in midnight mass was
outstanding sheriff hassan's monologue
on why he became a cop was one of the
most powerful and important moments of
tv i saw last year
so yeah you obviously are having an
impact on people
it's it's um
oh i didn't expect i don't the worst
kind of
i've i've ever felt about a project and
a cat work i've done is is sheriff
hassan
like i i thought i [ __ ] it and i
didn't speak to the cast during filming
i really worst imposters robert
longstreet who was in that who i just
did
he loves you i know you just had dinner
with him yeah yeah he just says you're
so good you're so committed to the role
you're so
uh you didn't talk to us to the cast
during the no because you know what the
character was sort of like an outsider
yeah and it was covered we were the
first show back one of the first shows
to make a show during kovitz so i we
were already bubbling we were already
isolated i had the worst imposter
syndrome i think i've ever experienced
in my entire career
i
didn't feel like there was a safety net
for me um
mike
gave me enough so mike was good enough
that i never spiraled in a way that
we're capable of spiraling but i was
still on the [ __ ] edge yeah and
i've never experienced this before like
we'd finish a scene and i'd sit in my
chair two hours i was crying head in my
hands i'm like i'm putting my worst work
to screen and there's nothing i can do
you really thought it was your worst 100
i mean it like it's not like
it's not some flowery way to then be
like and then it came out no it was the
what mike knew it my everyone everyone
could feel it around me i didn't believe
in anything i was doing
and
you know i'm not muslim
i'm not american i'm not 40. i don't
have a kid i'm so out of my depths with
this character um and then you never
know it oh dude
worst i like i was considering
a complete social media blackout phone
uh marooning i was going to do it the
gyroscope oh crazy what goes through
your mind yeah you just like everything
was coming down on you but knowing
that you it's it wasn't real it's not
real it's all in your head i guess
i guess i mean mike knew mike knew that
and like
i remember in somewhere like the show
came out in september and
september yeah and uh around about june
or something mike
we were doing something for netflix and
he was like you want to come watch it
it's great you're great come watch it
like [ __ ] i didn't want to [ __ ] do
this did you do it yeah me loving it in
his
theater and you loved it no
you didn't no i thought the sh i i
remember walking away going
you didn't break the show
which is a very arrogant thinking is
like we're so conceited we think that
our contribution we're going to make or
break it yeah we suck the show's done no
exactly so yeah that's when my biggest
fear was you got hamish link later and
kate siegel and and sam sloyan doing
these incredible performances
and you think you're gonna break the
show that's that's the attitude i had
and then i watched it and i walked away
going it's [ __ ] phenomenal despite
the crap you committed to screen
wow and and then the reviews came out
because you get them first and then they
all loved you yeah it was the isolated
like
you know people would like select you
amongst some of the other performances
and i was like
no [ __ ] [ __ ]
no way
i couldn't believe it i was like
i i i never i i there was no world in
which i ever thought that was possible i
remember saying out loud the best i'm
gonna hope for the best i hope for is i
never ever selected in a positive or
negative just don't talk about me
call it the ensemble i'll i'll be happy
that i didn't do anything like i didn't
break the show that crazy it's crazy
what goes through our minds i thought i
thought sometimes too and i'm bombing or
i'm embarrassed on set like i feel like
i'm not doing well and everyone's
watching everyone's like going what's
wrong with rosenbaum when he he used to
be a good actor he used to and i i've
had those things where i'm feeling so
nervous and i'm blushing in the face and
i i get offset and i'm like oh my god
nobody's looking me in the eye oh my god
it was so terrible and it's like all in
your [ __ ] head on your head
stop i felt that on mass i was like
they're not talking to me
everyone else is celebrating all the
stuff and with me and they're like hey
how you doing and i was like i don't
have the respect of my cast
i'm i'm bombing and everyone can see it
i'm [ __ ] bombing unbelievable
terrible and and then it would make the
accident more terrible
because i wasn't i wouldn't commit
certain days if i was really insecure i
wouldn't you need to be free with things
like that did he say something like i'm
the accident i'm hearing the accident
again yeah oh yeah oh yeah mike mike was
fantastic i mean mike's a very gifted
yeah impersonator right he's incredible
like he can do accents from around the
world mike's amazing and he's a pretty
[ __ ] good actor too
so he'd come over and be like you know
you said dolphin wrong you put an f in
it and i'd go oh [ __ ]
yeah dolphin things like dolphin uh it's
just awesome exactly so he'd do that and
and that would help but
now dude like i
the the thing is is like what i didn't
expect to happen
was
how uh
the islamic community
yeah
how about that that was the one and i
was like oh [ __ ] the performance i don't
care [ __ ] it if americans thought i was
american or didn't think i was american
or whatever i don't care
the the way that there were thesis being
written about it and
it was being pointed
um
to uh by people in the community as what
they'd like to see more of in terms of
representation absolutely that's all
that mattered and what a strong
character for the community for the
world it was just like
it's just and you're such a soft-spoken
character and you're trying to do the
right thing with your son you're trying
to listen to him but you're just like
you got to see it you got to see
midnight mass it's it was it's it's
really a great
character-driven story the problem with
that is like it wasn't rewarding
because as actors you want to come in
and to feel like you did your job you
want to hit a tent right you want to
scream shout
fight aggressive and then you want to
all high five as you leave and go
you left nothing on the you know you
left nothing out there oh my god it was
everything but the kitchen sink and i
committed to a choice to never go past a
certain level
until they until i go mama bear and they
attack my cub
and that was the choice i committed and
we didn't do that scene until the last
week of filming so i spent six months
feeling like an imposter
and always dealing with scenes where i
just go
and then we'd rap and you go i don't i
don't feel like i've done anything but
i'm committing to this i don't want to
raise my voice i don't want to be
aggressive i want to be chill
um so it wasn't rewarding to make but
then when i watched it and when i saw
the reception i was like ah
it was a good choice not to do that so
maybe next time
think of all that think of the fact if
you get in your head again say remember
how great you were and you didn't think
about it and you got all these accolades
and people talking about you in the
community and always remember that that
would be the performance that's the [ __ ]
one
is the one remember that you're like
yeah we'll [ __ ] you up
this has been a real treat for me thank
you really great what a wonderful person
to talk to you're really great i mean
it's
i really enjoyed it it was so easy to
talk to you i look at my notes but like
twice and i didn't even say anything
from my notes i felt like i steamrolled
it i came in and just went like
it was great you talked about everything
i i really appreciate it man i wish you
the best of luck and i can't wait to
hear the new project after the fall of
the house of usher that you're filming
now watch midnight mass watch blind
manor i zombie if you want just don't
watch the finale don't watch the finale
but you're doing so much great work and
i know there's so much great work to
to
what what's the word i'm looking for to
be done to be done that didn't sound
right to come to be had
to come to come that's it
to come
i like saying that
to come there's more to come
ah thanks man this has been awesome
thank you it's been a pleasure
just uh a good dude liked him
he's constantly working i like his
stories i like how he was you know
broke nothing's happening and then
something happens it's just like you
never know when things are to turn your
way oh in a week
[Music]
his life turned around so quick yep
god
i mean that's just the thing with life
if you're having a bad day you're having
a bad week a bad month just know that
there's a light at the end of the tunnel
guys there's there's things that are
going to get better they will get this
is life
it's not all good it's not all bad it's
a plethora of everything all the [ __ ]
you could think of you get
[ __ ] thrown at you constantly and it's
how you deal with it and uh
boy am i trying to deal with it uh i
hope you are and thank you again for
listening today uh a big shout out to
all the top tier patrons and all the
patrons in general if you want to join
patreon uh and support the podcast go to
patreon.com inside of you it's right
here and if you want us to uh follow us
and write a review which would help
immensely uh
that inside of you pod on twitter that's
right and city podcasts on instagram and
facebook that's correct and you can go
to the inside of your online store get
some cool merch or thesunspin.com
for band merch we've got all sorts of
stuff i will be
as far as i know i will be in st louis
in may um at a con i will be in
liverpool in may for a con i will be in
australia in june for a con illinois
metropolis illinois in june so come see
me come see me at a con
we'll have some fun
i love i love seeing people and seeing
patrons i get to see uh some patrons in
arkansas that came up to me um
kathy jo burks was there she's a patron
she came up to me and i was like hey
it's it's berks i'm like oh my gosh
and then there was david hoffman i was
like oh my gosh david hoffman's here it
was cool man it's cool so thank you
patrons um and the top tier patrons get
to a shout out they get a shout out
at the end of every episode and so
without further ado i will read them to
you and thank you for supporting the
podcast please continue to do so here
are the top tiers nancy d leah s sarah v
little lisa yukiko jill e bryan
h nico p robert b jason w kristen k
amelia o allison el raj c joshua
d cjp jennifer n stacy l gen
z no
[ __ ] c isn't it c s gen n s
jamal f janelle b kimberly mike e l dan
supremo
99 more ramira santiago m chad w leanne
p g
janine r
maya p maddie s belinda n chris h dave h
spiderman chase sheila g brad d ray h
tabitha t tom n liliana a talia m betsy
d chad l rochelle marion megkay trav l
den n danin
dannon
by dannon
that's a younger i think that's mennon
dannon was a yogurt yeah he still is
good call i like dannon big stevie w
angel m rhiannon c corey k super sam dev
nixon michelle a jeremy c andy t cody r
gavinator david c john b brandy the uh
vore camellia s the
c joey m willie f adelaide and omar i
lena anne design otg eugene
what eugene and
leah oh remember no i did not sorry
obviously chris p nikki g carrie
or corey corey
patricia heather l jake b james b
bobbitt at a
ebola f
able f ebola f
joshua b tony g sean r megan t mel s
orlando c john b caroline r darren b
robbie paul c christine
s sarah s
eric h and spring
spring
uh you guys don't know how much uh it
means to me that you listen to the
podcast and you support me and you
support ryan and you support bryce who's
the producer and you support jason our
amazing editor and uh westwood one and
cumulus thank you guys for uh supporting
the podcast again there's so many
podcasts out there and uh
you guys commit to it every week and uh
you know again thank you i hope i could
do this
for a while longer
we'll see what happens people keep
listening then maybe i'll keep doing it
but uh
that's all i could say um
ryan get anything else
that is all you could say you literally
stopped
that's all i could say oh my god he's
stopped on the diamond
breath i'm out of words jesus i don't
know what to do with myself i don't know
what to do with myself um just keep
doing it by the way i hope uh after this
the oscars will already be over but i
hope that coda won
dude i watched it last weekend awesome
cried for 45 minutes i tried to like
there's like one scene that starts and
then just like boom boom yeah watch koda
if you're gonna watch anything watch
coda
c-o-d-a
and you you know i give i give uh my
opinion sometimes
you're gonna thank me for this
uh from michael rosenbaum here in the
hollywood hills of california from right
there's
with his mustache
tell us what you think of ryan's
mustache i'd like to know what you think
and uh
i always see comments about uh ryan too
i love ryan and uh so they love you ryan
i appreciate it they do i'm happy to be
here yeah i'm happy you're here yeah uh
a little wave of the camera thank you
guys thank you for making me uh your
choice in podcasts and until next time
be good to yourself
be good to yourself and
you'll get through whatever you're going
through
all my love thank you for allowing me to
be inside of you today
[Music]